hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from round 10 of the
feeder candidates tournament 2022 it's
young sister of duda versus fabiano
corona and it is uh well it's basically
a story of how a certain player played
with absolute engine precision for like
10 straight moves in a row like 10
straight moves in a row uh you know just
uh throwing out the uh you know the the
top uh engine recommendation and just
refuting the idea completely so you'll
see what i mean by this as it's not a
very long game uh but uh you know what
we've seen so far in the candidates
there have been really really short
games like games like
you know under 30 moves so anything like
40 moves or above is a longer game
for for this particular candidates
tournament but okay now let's dive
straight into it quite a lot to enjoy
and yes uh i am definitely planning to
cover the uh the ding uh uh game as well
uh so uh nowhere is there and we will
get to that rapport uh attacks like a
madman being defended like you know
brilliantly it's it's a very enjoyable
game so uh let's enjoy this one uh duda
has the white pieces and he opens with
e4 we have e5 knight f3 knight to c6 and
the bishop to c4 going for the uh
italian game with bishop to c5 joco
piano and now uh of course we will not
be seeing this so we 2022 is still too
early for that we have c3 yeah going for
the main line of the joko piano knight
to f6 and now d3 we have these six
castles and a6 so this is all been uh
seen many many times on this channel as
well a4 bishop to a7 and now rook to e1
we have castles and now upon the h3
preventing the bishop from coming to g4
bishop to e6 now and here bishop
captures an e6 giving fabi the semi-open
f file f captures and now pawn to b4 now
fabi interestingly already had this
position uh as he uh plays it quite a
lot with the white pieces himself he had
it against nakamura and uh he uh uh uh
fabi lost to him in the in
saint louis blitz tournament of 2016
where queen to b3 was played but here
fabi uh improves with pawn to b4
uh and now knight to h5 going after this
knight knight to f4 square and also
interestingly karana had this exact same
position against alexander grishog in
the grand chest to rapid the tournament
in paris
where uh rook to a2 was played as
there's quite a lot of pressure on that
f2 pawn so rook to a2 makes sense but
here we have knight beat to d2 and it is
now as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game so luda says i know
you are familiar with these positions
fabi but i have just improved on the
games that you have played so let's see
what fabi can do with this knight to f4
of course it's a beautiful square for
the knight uh you can kick it away with
the e pawn and it's unlikely that you
will play g3 because you already played
h3 so you don't want to weaken your king
side all that much so here knight to f1
by duda queen to f6 fobby putting even
more pressure on that f2 pawn and now we
have to capture the knight here if we
don't then knight captures on h3g
captures we can capture the knight on f3
it's not very very good for black so
instead of just the bishop captures uh
for white uh so bishop captures on f4
queen captures and now queen to b3 fabi
does have a double e pawn and the e6
pawn is is very weak so of course duda
wants to attack it later on he can play
knight to g5 put more pressure on it
rook to f6 fabi defends it also prepares
to bring the other rook into the game
and now pawn to b5 grabbing more space
here on the queen side kicking away the
knight knight to the a5 attacking the
adidas queen queen to a2 and now fabi
plays pawn to g5 and this is probably
something uh maybe not this exact same
position but something that fabi uh
planned uh
uh
as he did prepare this for for the
candidates tournament so it's a very
double-edged g4 is coming you want to
open up the g file put the rooks on the
g file and uh
go for an attack against the white king
the white queen is a bit a little bit
displaced here on a2 so maybe fabi can
use this and the bishop of course is a
monster uh so this uh this is definitely
the way to go if fabi wants to catch
nepo uh and the content for uh for first
place in the candidates tournament and
here this is what i meant where one of
the players just goes on a complete um
uh
you know
engine moves free uh and the duda starts
with the knight one to h2 uh so okay uh
it's a nice move what what does it do
well it prevents phobia from executing
g4 right away so rook to g6 fabi again
prepares g4 and now d4 also very
important this is something that you
kind of have to play because this bishop
is just too strong and you don't want it
here uh you're not going to be able to
move the knight as this is a very very
weak pawn for the moment the queen
defends it yes but um
it's still best to just block this
diagonal completely so here h5 now fabi
again preparing g4 and now pawn to g3
chases away the queen queen to f6 and
now rook 8 to d1 so this is all every
move the absolute top engine move that
that duda is playing and here uh fabi
can start advancing the pawns but it's
not really it's not really all that
impressive for example you play g4 here
knight stage four we move the knight
with tempo and you don't have to worry
so here fabi plays rook to g7 uh and now
comes uh king the h1 now we are making
room for the rooks and the g file if the
g file opens up and chances are that it
will uh it will be
very useful for us and now this is
basically fabi's last chance to go for
g4
but he doesn't like it he goes for rook
to fate instead which puts even more
pressure on that f2 square
but now uh
duda just goes for it he could start
with g4 right away but he first captures
once d captures d captures and now he
goes for ponte h4 and this wins the g5
square
and there's nothing you can do about
this if you if you go for g4 which looks
like a good idea knight to g5 and uh
well it's just a terrible terrible
position for black for example if you
captured the pawn on f2 uh it's a game
over queen captures an e6 with czech
king has to move now we play rook to f1
the queen has to move we're gonna
capture the rook it's game over and even
if you don't do something like this if
you keep regarding the pawn what can you
play rook to g6 we are attacking it with
the knight and with the queen
still f3 is just
crushing there's no good move here for
example captures knight captures on f3
and there is no move black can make here
it's just a disgusting position to even
look at the rook is coming to d7 and
there's no move you can make here
so instead after h4 g captures on h4 by
fabi of course fabio wasn't going to
allow that position g captures on h4 so
the g file opens up and now uh fabi has
to figure out how to go about this the
knights are incredibly strong one of the
things in chess that you often hear is
that the knights should never be
defending each other because if one
moves then you can just capture the
other one but here you never want to
move them they are perfect as they are
and they are just a you know an
unbreakable pair uh so here bishop the
c5 fabi now once of course he doesn't
want to see uh rook to d7 at any point
okay now the rook is in g7 but uh he
wants to close the d file and also uh
the bishop isn't really all that useful
here anymore so here rook the g1
offering a rook trade and now bishop to
d6 this is how a little by little fobby
improves the position but now comes
knight to g5 putting more pressure on
this e6 pawn and the king the h8 fabi uh
gives it up and it seems like you should
capture this right away and what's
interesting is that's exactly what you
should do
but oh it looks a little bit weird but
the point is after knight captures we
are attacking the two rooks and of
course you're going to trade here with
check rook captures rook captures play
rook to g8 and now after you capture
let's say rook captures king captures
you can play knight to g5 open a
discovery here and this is winning for
for white no questions asked but it
still looks maybe a little bit scary but
you control all the squares you don't
have to worry this cover this is covered
um and it is just a much much better
position for white but okay duda goes
for queen to e2 first he wants to
capture on h5 and now fabi defends queen
to g6 uh we have rook to d3 now
preparing to double up here on the g
file a captures on b5 but duda doesn't
waste time recapturing he just brings
the rook into the attack rook d to g3
and now you can't really capture here if
you capture then we just capture here
and then we just attack everything
there's no defending this queen has to
move we're going to capture on g7 that's
the game over so instead queen to e8 now
uh getting the queen out of harm's way
and now we have a captures on b5
again you could just play knight
captures on e6 it's perfectly possible
uh because we are now attacking the rook
and g7 three times and if rook captures
we can still capture you can never
capture the knight here because queen
captures on h5 will result in checkmate
uh so that that was definitely the way
to go but okay now do the weights the
move playing a characters on b5 his
position is so much better than that he
can actually allow this but the only
problem is
you know if you play a sub optimal move
uh several times in a row then fabio
will take advantage of that and here we
have rook to f6 adding a defender to the
sixth rank and more precisely the uh the
e6 pawn and the problem is uh duda has
20 minutes on the clock fabi only has
five minutes on the clock and it's moved
31.
so here we have queen to f1 now
preparing to bring the queen over to g2
uh queen to d3 is also also very nice
but it's such a complicated position
that it's uh it's hard to say but
basically uh queen to d3 is the way to
go now uh still fabi doesn't have moves
here he can just wait to see what uh
aduda will do for example knight b3
we're going to capture on e6 as we can
always do this because of this pressure
here and after rook captures and g3
queen captures and again the knight is
immortal because of queen to g7 that
will be checkmate so again that was
possible but okay dude that goes for
queen to f1 and now we have b6 by fabi
now he wants to get the knight back into
the game via knight to b7 to c5 and with
all this pressure on the board it's hard
to imagine that fabi actually has time
to to accomplish this we have queen to
g2 again queen to d3 is always
always great because you can always
shift the queen over to g3
but queen to g2 by duda and now queen to
f8 uh we have uh queen to h3 now putting
pressure on that e6 pawn once again with
the knight and the queen and the queen
to g8 favi defense we have rook one to g
tuna adding a defender to the f2 pawn
and now knight to b7 fobby brings the
knight into the game and this is where
the fireworks start so the position of
this knight basically is what allows do
that this beautiful beautiful
combination uh that starts with knight
to h7 it's a spectacular move i thought
about making this deposit video moment
but maybe it would be too difficult so i
uh lowered it by by a few moves i hope
you guys don't mind but yeah knight
stage seven here puts pressure on the
rook here and you have to capture if you
if you play for example something like
this and try to give up the queen for
for the rooks it's not really all that
impressive the knight and bishop
are out of the game it's not like i mean
the bishop is basically a pawn here so
you don't have all that much to show for
white white would be better here and
winning so instead we have rook f the g6
by fabi now tripling up on the g file
rook captures on g6 rook captures and
denied back to g5 and now again there's
this constant pressure on the e6 pawn
and fabi has to make a move he makes
rook to f6 and i mean it's a move why
not
but now uh duda has a spectacular move
that i want you guys to
find so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find this spectacular
idea while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh grabbing that
knight on b7 i know it sounds impossible
but that's exactly what you have to do
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is pawn to f4 that's
the move and i know you guys are
thinking like okay f4 like what does it
do it's it's a free pawn
yes but after you grab this free pawn uh
you give up another pawn pawn to e5 and
all of a sudden you've opened up this
diagonal uh
towards the the b7 knight and also the
bishop is hanging and the rook is
hanging so you have to capture the pawn
and once the pawn is captured queen f3
now attacks the knight and also
threatens queen captures on h5 which
will result in checkmate so you lose the
knight whatever black plays we just
captured the knight it's a free piece
and if you try to save the knight of
course this is now checkmate queen
captures an h5 king g7 knight captures
an e6 a discovery from the rook and also
a check from the night so
you know
as that quote goes in the face of even
the the bravest king uh
flees in the face of a double check or
something like that
it's a fun quote but i never seem to
remember it correctly uh but okay after
f4 of course the pawn cannot be captured
so knight to c5 fabi tries activating
the knight uh but now comes f captures
on e5 this is uh of course you have to
capture bishop captures an e5 and not
knight g back to f3 opening up a
discovery towards the black queen and
also attacking the bishop here and this
is how we win the piece so we didn't win
the knight on b7 but uh
you know fabi had to
try and save the knight so he had to
give up the bishop so queen to a8 now
fabi has to give up the piece and he
will try to pose some problems for duda
with some checks knight captures an e5
knight captures an e4 and now knight h
to f3 again the knights uh defend each
other and it's uh it is just beautiful
so queen to a1 with check king to h2 now
comes queen to c1 but there's nothing
more for for uh fabi to try here knight
the d3 attacks the queen queen captures
on c3 and now rook to a2 going after the
attack asking are you maybe interested
in a knight here uh because if you
capture the knight of course rook to a8
check and after the king moves queen to
g to check you will uh not be able to
survive this wherever you go queen to g8
and it's it's game over even if you go
here uh then it's just rook to h8
checkmate so it's a it's a definitely a
a fine attack by duda so knight to f2 uh
going after the attack attacking the
queen and attacking the knights twice uh
rook captures on f2 and now queen
captures on d3 so basically trading
knights in a fancy way uh we have queen
to g3 now uh defending the rook and
queen to d6 uh again it's um
you don't really have a good move here
now with uh do this queen controlling
the g file rook to d2 will be deadly uh
so you can't afford this uh fabio goes
for a trade he he does have two pawns
for a piece but i mean the the pawns are
not very well connected the king is
completely out of the game you are not
well suited
to play this on so queen captures c
captures king g3 duda starts bringing
the king into the game rook to f5 goes
after the b5 pawn but now rook to d2 of
course also going after the pawns here
fabi trades rook captures rook captures
and now king the g7 but the e pawn also
falls rook captures on e6 rook to b4 and
now rook to e5 going after the h5 pawn
king h6 now rook to d5 we have rooked
the b1 and now knight to d4 we have
rooked the g1 check king to f4 and he
was in this position on move 57 that
fabiano caruana resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here he
is just down a clean piece and there you
know it would be it would be incredibly
impolite
even pretend that there's a chance maybe
that the duda would mess this up because
the there really isn't so of course fabi
doesn't want to do that he resigns and a
wonderful wonderful victory for young
who gets his first win in defeating
candidates tournament 2022 and uh so i
don't forget uh here is uh a photo of
the moment where fabi resigned you can
see it's uh it's a very firm handshake
so fabi definitely uh thinks that to do
that deserved the win he refuted the
attack perfectly fabi had to push very
hard with the black pieces if he wants
to catch uh nipple who is now a full
point and a and a half ahead of everyone
in the race but uh
like i said duda just turned into an
engine here with this g5 move uh fabi
fabi prepared it well i mean the engine
loves g5
and you have to play it with the
absolute engine precision if you want to
survive the attack but uh look at this
uh knight h2 first engine choice uh then
d4 by do that first engine choice then
g3 first engine choice then rook eight
the one first engine choice even king
the h1 first engine choice uh and then
even this captures with h4 first engine
choice so incredible uh how duda just
refuted this would uh you know would
just the simple brute force
it's spectacular a spectacular play by
duda uh so yeah i hope you guys enjoyed
that and the nice handshake photo here
are the standings so we are like i said
we're going to show the ding rapport
game but just in case you know something
happens i don't want to leave you guys
hanging without the standings so here
are the standings nipple seven out of
ten incredible stuff uh a full point and
a half ahead of everyone but now tied
for second place we have fabiana karwana
hikaru
so ding who had a very rough start to
the candidates tournament like he did in
the previous candidates tournament now
is sharing second place after getting
the two wins fabi very unlucky in the
last three games he lost two games and
and got one draw so basically kind of
the durian uh it kind of ruined the
tournament for him and hikaru just doing
incredibly well you've seen that uh
brilliant victory against alireza he
played today that was a spectacular
stuff rajablam and fifth duda and
rapport uh sixth and seventh and the
alireza furuja in eighth place uh so
there we have it those were the
standings hope you enjoyed that as well
uh really really enjoying uh
watching the games you know just
listening about the candidates
tournament you know everyone is enjoying
themselves uh posting all sorts of stuff
on twitter and you know everyone
predicting will magnus play what will
happen uh who you know if um
if hikaru uh
now gets maybe to play uh uh we we could
have a four people tie at the top so
absolutely anything would happen uh but
yeah once again i really hope you
enjoyed this i would like to wish a very
happy birthday to ori and i would like
to thank a friend from the bar in the
library disgusting engine line kenneth
frazier and clever piggy for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
candidates until it finishes
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day